Karthus Sanwa it wasn't always here this
deep underground it originally appeared
a few layers higher rocketing through
the catacombs of Karthus but the Karthus
grave ordinance devised a way to drive
it out with clever use of lightning
resistant yellow bug pellets they
repelled the sand worm so effectively
that it tumbles deep below to its new
home in the smoldering lake and if you
look carefully you can actually see how
much of its body is comprised of its
victims
and it's these Karthus corpses that
we're discussing today because the sand
worm exists at the end of the Karthus
time line and we're more interested in
the beginning in what happened to the
sand kingdom above the catacombs the
empire that would conquer the world
theoretically when you exit the Karthus
catacombs you should be faced with
rolling sand dunes and a blistering Sun
but you're not you're kind of met with
the stark opposite when you see ferrand
swamp
that's strange and I'll explain why that
is at the end of this video but for now
I want you to imagine this arid desert
kingdom setting because that is the
kingdom that we're piecing together this
was an empire that was won by the
warriors of Carver's almost every
civilization in souls has this single
characterizing drive that motivates
their warriors mirror is driven by
knighthood and honor demon kind is
driven by this desperate need for
survival and the Warriors of Karthus
were characterized by their lust for
victory this inspired a culture that is
focused on combat techniques and the
ability to achieve victory through any
means necessary with their own brand of
sharpened titanite warriors of Karthus
fought with heavy curved swords some of
which were specifically designed to
curve around the shields of their
enemies if they found themselves at a
distance from their enemy they would peg
these small machetes at them called
kukri
and if they were in melee range they
could use their blood rings to sort of -
around the battlefield like a cloud of
sand but there's more to their
techniques with the development of
spells such as Karthus flame arc and
Karthus beacon they developed a school
of supplemental pyromancy that was
entirely divergent from other forms so
in the tree of pyromancy there was a
branch of Karthus pyromancies and no
pyromancy captured their love of victory
quite like the spell acid surge did
pyromancy of Karthus of the sense emits
an acid which corrodes weapons and armor
Karthus swordsmen attached great value
to victory and would not shun the use of
such pyromancies for where is the honor
in death and scoured bones in addition
to this one there was the beacon
pyromancy which likens Karthus 'as
aggression to an uncontrollable fire
this spell rewards you for being
recklessly offensive and was activated
during war to serve as this silent
secret signal for attack
so with tools such as these they toppled
other kingdoms and likely used their
resources to fuel their own kingdom so
compare Karthus
ideology to a place like mirror like
mirror Karthus is this war-torn country
that revolves around its fighters but in
contrast mirror has this huge focus on
knighthood and honor to the point where
they would actively avoid using magic
because it would be seen as unlikely to
do so they would only ever use magic the
only time they truly needed it to face
the magic of an enemy a Karthus warrior
on the other hand would imbue his pre
sharpened sword with fire buff himself
with a secret pyromancy art throw a
machete at your face cast a cloud of
acid to eat away at your weapons roll
around you as this invisible invincible
cloud of sand and leave his shield
ignoring Chatel
with your blood McArthur's Warrior is
basically the kind of dude who summons
at the pontiff's arena it's someone who
has min maxed all of their stats someone
who spends a minute buffing themselves
before the duel and who drinks Estes if
they're about to lose but moving on
insoles a crown is representative of the
power and the influence that you wield
it's the sign of a rightful monarch and
that was a huge theme in Dark Souls 2
and it's kind of represented in Dark
Souls 3 by wall Nia who brought rightful
Lords to their knees ground their crowns
to dust and conquered them all their
crowns became one kind of like in the
dark souls2 cinematic and their kingdoms
became his as well with wall Nia
becoming the one High Lord of a vast
vast empire his warriors lived for their
high lord wall Nia who was the Conqueror
of most kingdoms known to their people
and while wall near definitely didn't
have much respect for monarchs wall near
did respect prowess with the blade below
the catacombs we loot the black blade
which is a short katana that was once
wielded with a rare technique the
swordsmen who wielded it was and I quote
a distinguished guest of high load well
now though considering his blade is
found in the crypts now I'm kind of
thinking that his distinguished guests
might be dead and that sort of ties in
to our next point wall Nia was motivated
by a unique goal called the wish in the
Japanese text he didn't just want to
conquer kingdoms he specifically wanted
to become the last of the dead to
outlive all to conquer kingdoms was kind
of just a byproduct of this and so it
was that his main goal was to sentence
countless souls to death and this seems
to have included a bunch of clerics who
possessed some truly powerful artifacts
of the way of white I count three holy
bracelets
a divine greatsword so these would come
in handy for walnut later in life
because true to the Karthus ethos of
victory at all costs wall nia began
experimenting with the abyss this
resulted in new dark pyromancies but
wall Nia slipped a lot further than he
intended and he experienced a fear of
true darkness and he clung to the
strength of the gods for the first time
in his life note the English description
says that wall near pleaded with the
gods no wall near didn't plead that's
not in his character at all
instead the Japanese clarifies that he
clung to the power of the gods because
their divinity naturally defies the
abyss and was these items these
artifacts of the gods that were imbued
with power it wasn't necessarily walnut
who had faith so thanks to these holy
braces and the sword that he pillaged
from those way of white clerics that he
killed wall near was able to fight off
being completely consumed by the abyss
and it's unclear how present he was in
his kingdom henceforth but I think he
still had some influence over his
kingdom because afterwards his grave
wardens were able to pioneer new
pyromancies spells that imparted the
will of humanity to fire like black
serpent which traces along the ground as
if it had a life of its own but perhaps
it was precisely these events this
tinkering with the abyss that would draw
the abyss Watchers to the kingdom of
Karthus to stand bow to the dark that
was rising there in Dark Souls 3 it's
not just time that's convoluted it's the
geography of the world as well we
mentioned at the start that it's not a
sand kingdom that exists above the
catacombs of Karthus as it should in
Dark Souls 3 instead I think fur and
swamp exists above the catacombs of
Karthus because the two places are
linked that it was the abyss Watchers of
Ferren who trampled upon wall knees
abyss putting an end to the sand kingdom
of Karthus and that it was likely wall
near who dragged the abyss Watchers with
him
we go over that point a little bit more
in this video which features 10 secrets
of war from the souls series so check it
out and join me as we wrap up all of the
remaining law of this series because the
Dark Souls series is at its end for now
and hopefully we learn a little bit more
about our future at e3 I'm so excited
for that but for now I'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
you